hello and welcome to offensive golang
bonanza
uh so what this talk is gonna be there's
two ways to consume it one you can just
listen to me describe a whole bunch of
going malware components and you'll get
a sense of what's out there what's
available what's possible
and if you want to go in depth there are
links on all of the slides to
the actual code repos themself
code samples interviews news articles
all kinds of stuff
so to start with uh i'm going to do a
little bit of backstory on my
my my hacker crew and a little bit on
golang and why it's so interesting to
malware developers and then we'll start
going through various components and
tools
so in the beginning
i was interested in
anti-censorship surrounding a particular
iranian election uh i was uh taking a
look at the torah obfuscation proxy of
proxy 2 at the time
and i thought i could do better and so i
started the ratnet project
which is a pretty cool uh
nids evasion thing we're going to talk
about later
and i was using that project as an
excuse to learn golang and what i
learned is that golang is magic
unlike any programming language i've
used before you just anything you you
need anything you would normally have to
install as a separate library or utility
is just there for you everything from uh
crypto networking libraries uh virtual
file systems are supported natively
which is totally unique uh the compiler
cross-compiles easily to every other uh
architecture and operating system uh
there's built-in uh test frameworks uh
vendoring frameworks uh it's garbage
collected it has a very efficient thread
implementation
and it has its own assembler
and the third-party library support is
totally unparalleled uh so rust is years
away just to answer the question of why
don't i rewrite everything in rust
but the main reason that i love go
is that it is the fastest way to be done
and my
goal is not to reinvent every wheel my
goal is to when i start a project is to
be done with the project and use the
project um
and the the fastest way to learn go the
way i learned is a document called
effectivego on the golang website which
assumes that you already know how to
program and just tells you what's
different about go i would highly
recommend that to anyone who wants to
learn go
especially if you already know how to
program
so a few relevant facts about go
it is not interpreted i'm not sure why
people seem to get that misconception it
is statically compiled however um
it also every go binary includes a a
kind of monolithic run time
uh which is like 800k uh on most
operating systems so that's a it's a bit
of overhead per binary and then all of
your code is statically compiled on top
of that all the dependencies and
everything that aren't already in the
run time
the uh the embedded assembly language is
based on plan 9's assembly language so
it's a little bit crazy
we don't have time to go into it
but i did a write-up that will kind of
help you cope it's linked on this slide
i recommend checking that out
so to get into the story so stuxnet
happened and everyone got very hot on
environmental keying
environmentally keyed payloads uh josh
pitts made a tool in goling to do
environmentally key payload keyed
payloads called ebola it got very
popular with the red teamers at the time
and so uh all the edrs and av companies
wanted to write sigs for ebola
uh but they had never seen a golang
hacker tool before and so they all ended
up
writing signatures for the golang run
time which is included in every going
process
so what happened next is that all of the
av utilities triggered on every go
binary including the installer
but it also included the very prevalent
orchestration tools you know docker and
terraform and so as a result they all
had to pull those sigs very quickly
because
you know people need their terraform
and this is a
a pattern that malware developers look
for
we call the jar to exe pattern
where basically if you have anything
that makes a native
binary for you
but it's
it has one legitimate user that means
the av companies need to whitelist it
and they have trouble creating sigs for
like java inside a jar 2exe
binary they have trouble creating sigs
for python inside of pi to exe
binary if those are white listed and
similarly they have trouble creating
sigs
for a go code which is statically
compiled past the go run time
uh so realizing that and also i i had
this sweet exfiltration library i've
been working called ratnet ratnet
i started uh talking to other security
people that were interested in go
and we got together shared ideas things
escalated very quickly
and
we uh
you know this has happened in the past
with uh python now it's happening with
go
um and we made uh a bit of a community
um probably the best
uh example of this is there's a
particular slack
server uh uh where pound going the slack
channel
um
has
like literally
uh
it's like the best place on the internet
it has like all
all the people uh working in um going
malware basically hang out there they
share ideas they're really nice to each
other um there's no kind of like
political or weird other internet
nonsense it's just people you know
helping each other with projects
suggesting project ideas
um and it's uh it's just amazing uh so
we're gonna talk about tools from a lot
of people in this chat room um i bought
i bold faced the uh the the ones that
are specifically mentioned in this deck
but uh everybody in there uh just thank
you it's been uh totally
uh critical for my sanity uh especially
over the last year um and i especially
want to thank uh the the community
organizer jeff mcjunkin for keeping most
of the crazy out
um
so uh just a quick word about you know
offense and defense all of these tools
are open source
uh we we post the code we hope that the
people who work on operating system uh
and
defenses and defensive tools will study
these and learn how they can
improve
some of the
the the problems that especially the
bypass tools uh exploit have been around
for 10 20 in some cases 30 years
um so having
uh you know
there's no it's not oh day it's just
like
you know things have been broken for a
long time
you can't just bury your head in the
sand
so we're trying to make things better by
helping people understand how things
actually work
and on that note i'm going to talk
briefly about what tools exist for
reversing go binaries uh there aren't a
lot that are useful
even now the most useful one is probably
the go reversing tool kit they have a
tool called redress
which is fairly successful at extracting
metadata from stripped go binaries
including dependencies and compiler
versions and then there's a few uh ida
scripts and blog posts uh linked on this
slide uh which gives you some clues as
to how to go about reversing a go binary
but it's it's it's still pretty
primitive and i think a lot of the
trouble is that is the static
compilation aspect if you've ever tried
to
open up an embedded
you know c program that's statically
compiled in ida you end up having to
sort of manually work out what a lot of
the functions do there are kind of flirt
flare signatures but i haven't
um
i haven't seen that for golang yet
um so some of the core components
for the rest of the tools we're going to
talk about
the first one the one that gets used by
almost everything
uh is our our fork of goes standard
debug library so go comes with a
library called debug the parses uh all
binary formats p e uh for windows alpha
linux uh and mac o for os x
um we forked that uh fixed a bunch of
bugs um and added uh support for uh
editing the file changing things by
their fields you know and uh and then
writing the file back out
uh once you've changed it um so
we we turned it into an arbitrary binary
modification framework uh and we also
made it uh parse files that are already
loaded into memory and also you can
write them back out to memory but you
need a tool we're going to talk about
later um
but this is especially cool because you
can parse your own process
which lets you do a lot of neat malware
tricks um as we'll see and uh you can
also inject shell code into um
a file on disk which is also pretty
handy
um
so the
parser entry points for you know pe all
from maco are always either new file or
new file from memory
um the generator entry points are always
called bytes in case you're looking at
the code
also some of the stuff we added we added
base relocations and relocations uh we
added uh import address table fix-ups uh
the ability to add sections uh the
ability to hook entry points and the
ability to
access and add signatures which comes up
in a lot of the uh the malware tools
we're using but this might be useful for
other things as well
another core component is cppgo
we got this from lauren siegel we just
forked it and added support for the
apple m1 for arm64
basically this is a way uh from go to
make native calls into
uh any other library using any api any
calling convention uh so it comes with
standard call uh cducal and this call
and so this is absolutely critical uh
for a
a lot of uh malware functionality from
go i'd highly recommend you check it out
it's a great example of go assembler
moving on to the exploitation tools
category
uh our first exploitation tool
um is called injection and this uses the
uh the the binject debug binary
modification platform
and adds a layer on top of it which
implements a variety of different
algorithms for inserting shell code
into a binary predominantly hooking the
entry point but it wouldn't necessarily
have to be so there's a command line
utility you can also use it as a library
and so
it's very extensible and we've
implemented a variety of algorithms
including for pe the one we use the most
often these days is just adding a new
section you hook the entry point to
point at the new section at the at the
end of the new section you have it point
back to the original entry point
so basically file starts runs your shell
code in the new section jumps back to
the original entry point
modern pes don't have a lot of code cave
space anymore i guess there have been
compiler improvements so this is the
most successful method for pe we found
for elf we have a variety of different
methods we're probably going to add more
we have silvio cesari's original uh
padding infection method uh which we
updated a little bit so it supports uh
position independent executables um
and uh we also uh s blip uh from the
channel uh also implemented a completely
new uh injection method based on pt note
which is in there and
we also have uh
c tours or constructor hooking for
shared libraries so not only can you
hook an executable you can also inject
shell code into a shared library and
have that run when the library loads
for mock o we're predominantly hooking
the entry point and using the one giant
code cave which is in all macho binaries
before that first load segment um i'm
not
uh sure why that is always the case but
there's always one giant code game you
can fit a bunch of show code in i don't
know
just a quick example of what the code
looks like this is the whole uh
silvio method
from injection uh there are no there's
no weird offsets there's no hex math uh
you can just read it and it's referring
to the actual fields uh in in the file
format uh and that's the coming from
binjack to bug uh and this is the right
layer of abstraction that you want to
code uh injection algorithms in uh and
that's uh kind of the whole point so
it's easy to understand the algorithm
just by reading the code it's easy to
add new algorithms
now what kind of kicked off the bin jack
debug and injection project was a desire
to make
the old tool from josh pitts backdoor
factory work again so backdoor factory
stopped working and we were like hey
let's just rewrite this whole thing and
go we broke it into modules and we ended
up with bin jack the bug injection and
finally we needed to close the loop with
uh backdoor factory
um so
vector factory is a thing man in the
middle someone who's trying to download
a binary and inject shellcode into the
binary automatically it was beautiful
red teamers loved it it got used all the
time and then it stopped working and we
were all very sad um backdoor factory uh
originally worked with a tool called
ettercap which is terrible and old i
mean it worked at the time but it was
into curses
and there's a better go rewrite called
better cap
which adds support for more
man-in-the-middle methods
and
so we decided to use better cap for the
rewrite and then we already had
injection you know
uh
so
basically uh bettercap has a scripting
language called the caplet scripts and
they already had implemented a script
for bettercap called download autophone
which intercepts uh web downloads and
replaces them with a malicious payload
so it doesn't inject it into a file it
just replaces it entirely
um but we just started from that and
then in the caplet language only exposes
read file and write file commands that's
the only way you can interact with
anything outside of javascript
and so
we figure
we'll just make a named pipe server and
uh and use read file and write file to
pass the file being made in the middle
out to injection inject our shell code
and then uh use a read file to read it
back in through another pipe uh back
into the caplet and return it to the
user
so that looks like this so you can use
better cap to man in the middle
someone's download using
arp spoofing dns poisoning dhcp v6 or
anything else better cap supports
that their download request comes to you
you go out to the server they were
originally trying to access and download
the file they were trying to get and
then you pass that file through the new
pipe server the new backdoor factory
tube injection where the shell code gets
injected into the executables and then
the whole thing gets repackaged and
passed back uh to the user and they
think it was the file they were trying
to download
open it run it run your shell code
that's the general idea
so our implementation of backdoor
factory uh
you know lives in the binject
basically what it does it starts up this
pipe server it spits out the caplet and
better cap config files
that you need and it tells you exactly
what better cap command to run
um which is just mainly because i've
kept forgetting how to use better cap
you may need to customize that caplet
file and the better cap config you'll
have to customize the caplet if you want
to support different user agents
if you only want to trigger on certain
user agents you can do that very regular
expression or if you only want to
trigger on certain file extensions
extensions you can also edit that in the
caplet also by default it will do
arp spoofing that might be too loud if
you want to do dns poisoning you'll
you'll have to edit the default better
cap config that comes out of there
um so some features that we added we
added support for unpacking archives
so it'll actually uh
if someone's trying to download a tgz or
a zip file it will unzip that on the fly
inject all of the binaries inside it
then re-zip it and pass it back to the
user
we're also working on adding support for
re-signing the binary with a stolen or
purchased key
and uh well we'll word on that in a sec
um and uh we also ported this to the
wi-fi pineapple because back in the day
running uh back to our factory on a
malicious access point was super fun and
golang supports easy cross compilation
to mips 32 so there are links to the
better cap and backdoor factory packages
we made on this slide
so quick demo
so on the right
we're downloading
a file with wget
and
unzipping it running it and it says i'm
a simple program blah blah
now in the upper left we're starting the
pipe server
which opens up some named pipes to
injection
uh and it gave us generated some better
cap configs gives us the command to run
better cap in another window
we run better cap
and it starts the arp spoof
and intercepting files
using our caplet
so we go and download the same file we
just downloaded again
you can see the size is a little bit
different
unzip that
run the binary inside and uh you can see
it printed test in addition to the uh
the original command the original output
that is a shell code we made that we use
as a test uh shell code which uh prints
test so that's uh proof that our shell
code has been injected and also the
original program still ran
so that's the new backdoor factory um so
because the files are being passed in uh
by a pipe we actually don't we lose the
extension of the file on the way in um
we don't get that through the pipe um so
we're actually using uh mime
so we're using a go library to determine
the mime type uh and then where we have
the switch statement based on the mime
type of what uh injection to do like
that's how we figure out what file it is
so if you want to extend it uh you can
just extend it by mime type which is
actually pretty awesome
um
you know there's different mime types
for like jars than zips which is pretty
cool because uh some programs would tell
you they're the same format um
and
uh the the main uh call tip injection
looks like this inside backdoor factory
it's injective binary it does a quick um
check of the magic number to see if it's
a mock o l for p e
um and then it uh calls uh it pulls the
appropriate shell code and then calls
uh binject near the bottom there
to inject the appropriate shell code
into the binary
so
signing from golang
is also very well supported
the two main libraries i'd recommend
that you check out one is called
limelighter
which uh
it does athena code signing of exes and
dlls uh
you can either use a real cert or it'll
make one up for you which is also kind
of handy for edr evasion and another one
that's a little bit heavier but signs
everything is relic
and relic not only does the authentic
code signing stuff
it also supports like centos rpms
debian deb files java jar files
silverlight zap files which is pretty
handy
if you can still find some silverlight
um
powerscript android apks and macos and
dmgs for
for macs
so there's a lot of possibilities for uh
extending uh backdoor factory to new and
interesting file formats
so moving on to a different exploitation
tool uh from sisto we have go wi exec
which actually brings the ability to
just do remote uh wmi windows management
interface calls uh
to go which lets you just run random
shell commands on some target windows
machine out in space
there's also another library that gives
you full smb support
um
go smb2
and uh so if you put those two together
you can replicate impact its smb exact
functionality uh so you can you can
upload a file with go smb to a target
and then you can execute it with go w my
exec so you could put this in your
implant and have it like auto spread
or you can use this as an initial inject
assuming you have
credits for a windows box
um
and
so in code it's kind of just as easy as
this i couldn't fit all of the uh the
file upload stuff in there
but you can see the the wmi call uh
basically you just you pass it username
password uh or you can use a hash uh if
you have it um because cso is magic um
and uh like the domain and the client
name and stuff you can either randomize
those or they're optional
so it's you know it's pretty easy to use
um and for a full example of uh smb exec
and go including the the file upload
stuff check out the source code bundle
on the defcon media server
for my defcon 29 workshop writing
goaling malware
and there's a lot more detail in
in the workshop slides so some other
exploitation tools uh don't have time to
go into
but go fish is a very popular fishing
tool kit uh
um gobuster uh is is good for brute
forcing subdomains uh there's a little
dns server you can use for xxes it's
also good for dns blackholing which is
good for android reversing
and there's also modlichka which is a
phishing reverse proxy which has some
novel uh 2fa bypass stuff in it
so that those are all go repos you
should
check out or use as a reference
moving on to edr and nid's evasion tools
uh the most important one is garble this
is the state-of-the-art golang
obfuscator it does not do control flow
obfuscation
unfortunately but hopefully that's
coming
but it will strip out almost all uh go
metadata uh and with the the optional
dash literals command it will replace
string literals with uh lambdas uh which
is uh very important for avoiding sigs
um
and uh obviously it was a bit broken
um it uh uh
it was slow it didn't work with go
modules it had trouble with dependencies
garble fixes all of that it's actually
remarkably fast it's incredibly easy to
use and i haven't uh i haven't seen it
choke on anything at all yet which is
which is amazing so there's really no
reason not to use garble on everything
um as far as i know
and
definitely try that redress tool uh try
redress on something before you garble
it and then try it after you garble it
and see what happens uh that's probably
a good time
so uh in terms of nid's evasion uh
uh there's a lot of kind of network code
uh out there uh my own project is ratnet
um it works uh it has a couple of unique
features uh it works on store and
forward so it actually is not stream
based it bundles messages up into
batches
and each message is individually end to
end encrypted but the batches are also
encrypted separately for every hop
it works on mesh routing so every ratnet
node acts as a router
and uh it also supports plugable
transports you can have different
transports between hops you can also
support multiple transports at once
um and you can dynamically change
between transports so the transports
that we ship with
we have udp tls https which is like
cloud fronting
and we also have dns and aws s3 as a
transport uh
which is pretty neat um
and i this also works
without the internet as just a mesh
routing middleware and i'm working on a
handheld ratnet-based hardware device uh
which will come out as a crowd supply
next year so watch the space for that
so a couple of use cases
that we support with ratnet
one is uh say you've hit a bunch of
machines uh with an implant uh and you
uh not all of them have direct internet
access and you want to pivot uh you want
uh to be to be able to talk to all of
the implants uh
from your your c2
um
so what you can do is you can make an
implant where the implants find each
other using uh mdns or multicast
uh and
if they can't get to the internet
directly they will
just automatically route uh all of their
messages out through one of their peers
and if
if any one of those peers can find their
way out to the internet to the c2
you can actually it'll just
automatically make a network and you can
talk to all of the implants
because the implants in the middle will
automatically act as a router because
that's how rat networks
so there's actually a demo of this
working also in the workshop source code
the other use case that we want to
support is if you drop an implant into
an egress proxy data center
so if all web traffic or like almost all
traffic is blocked out to the open
internet from where you are
you can still usually get out with dns
because the local dns server will
hopefully pass
lookups out through recursion
so that's why the that's what the dns
transport is for
you also might find yourself in a
situation where lots of things are
blocked but some things are whitelisted
and in those situations typically aws is
whitelisted because almost everything is
using aws at least a little bit
so there's a lot of other ratna sorry
there's a lot of other going tunnels and
proxies to look at other than retina
so some of the popular ones are chashal
and chisel
which got used together in a ransomware
attack very recently there's a link in
this to a very uh interesting breakdown
of some ransomware that use those two
and there's also uh
wireguard is a distributed vpn which is
actually a commercial product which is
uh
implemented and go and very worth
checking out it's a lot easier to set up
than openvpn just in general um and uh
so there's a lot of other tunnel and
proxy code in go because go is typically
very stable um
probably more result of the built-in
testing framework than anything else but
uh
there's a lot of good network stuff and
go
moving on to uh
another edr evasion tool uh there's
pandora's box so i mentioned that golang
uh has native support for virtual file
systems that means that anytime in go
you're referring to a file um you can
totally control
the file abstraction it doesn't really
have to go to the file system
you can make a uh for example an
encrypted in-memory virtual file system
and use it exactly the same way from
your go code that you talk to normal
files and that is what pandora's box
does it basically is a shim between the
memguard library which tries as hard as
it possibly can to give you a secure
enclave in memory
to protect uh what you're putting in a
mem guarded region from tools like
volatility or other uh analysis tools
um
and uh so basically pandora's box is the
bridge between uh the golang file
abstraction and uh memguard
but it gives you a an encrypted vfs
very very easily
definitely
worth checking out
so
this is another one of my tools i call
it the universal loader um i implemented
reflective dll loading in golang for all
platforms uh including the the apple m1
so it actually works with arm64
this might be the first loader i've seen
anywhere that actually supports the m1
um although other than that it's basic
it's doing a lot of sort of traditional
reflective dll loading stuff
um so reflective dll loading basically
mimics the behavior of the the system
loader when it loads a dynamic library
into a process
it just does all the things the system
loader does as best it can
so it loads the library into the process
lets you call functions that were in the
library
but doing it reflectively means that you
never need to touch disc which is the
main advantage um if you never touch
disc maybe av never triggers um
you know
uh so uh
the uh
the back ends uh for the universal
loader for windows osx and linux are a
little bit different uh the the windows
method uh does not use the system loader
um it does use some go assembly uh to uh
walk the peb and uh figure out
um
uh and then it uses binject the bug to
like parse the process you're in and
like figure out um
the imports and exports of everything
um
and there's a branch of the universal
loader that actually does do import
address table fix-ups it's called import
address table
and
so
if you are
loading a library that depends on other
libraries you will definitely need to
use the uh the iat branch um the os x
method uh actually does use the system
loader uh we followed a training from
malware unicorn which i highly recommend
checking out on writing osx malware um
and it actually finds where the dynamic
loader library is in memory
and then
parses it with binject finds a couple of
key functions in there that for some
reason for some reason osx is the only
operating system that has
a built-in part of the operating system
that lets you load a library from ram
both windows and linux require a file
somewhere but osx does not so we just we
just use
that oh load a library from ram method
and
you know bob's your uncle so that's kind
of why we're using the system loader for
osx and no one else
and then the linux method
does not use the system loader either
but it also does not use mfd it really
does a reflective library load uh for
linux
mfd is a linux ram disk uh and uh the
previous loaders for golang just
dumped your
library to mfd and then uh just loaded
it with the l open
we do not do that although it is easy
and it works
use of mfd is unusual and it's easy to
detect
so
doing an actual reflective library load
is a bit stealthier
and that's what that's what we're doing
so this is what it looks like in code
the interface as i said in code is the
same for all operating systems basically
you got your library loaded in a buffer
you make a new loader with new loader
you call loader.loadlibrary that's the
universal loading your your buffer as a
library and that will under the hood
work differently
for whatever operating system you
compile it for but the interface remains
the same
and then you can just call exported
functions init
with that library.call where in this
example we're calling a function called
run me we're passing it the argument
seven
so this is just a super simple example
but it's going to be exactly like this
for every operating system the only
thing that will change is the the
library that you actually load
so a couple of notes
because you're not using the system
loader the the libraries that you're
dependent on will not automatically be
loaded for you so for windows you have
to use the iit branch as i said but then
every library that you depend on you
have to call syscall.muslo dll
for that library to make sure that it's
already loaded and present for you
before you use universal
but it'll automatically work it out from
there
and uh for linux um i would just
recommend that you statically compile
the libraries you need to load with
universal uh because you can do that for
linux it doesn't really work for windows
um but if you just statically compile
the library like that'll just work fine
and it's easy
all right moving on uh to our next tool
it's donut donut is amazing it is a
payload creation framework
that lets you convert any executable
dll.net assembly or like vbs to an
encrypted injectable shell code
uh and then it is also the the assembly
loader uh that decrypts and loads those
payloads into a process it is very
configurable uh definitely check it out
um
one of its cool features uh is that it
supports remote loads so you can
actually configure the loader to pull
down the rest of the payload from a web
server instead of having to to bundle it
in
uh which is pretty sick
um
and uh
so i ported the utility
that converts things to donut payloads
to go
so that you can use it from an implant
or from a c2 uh and you might be
wondering why would you want to do this
uh we'll see an example in a minute uh
it turns out to be a surprisingly handy
thing to do and because it's pure go you
can now do this from any operating
system
um so most people see twos are on linux
not windows
so that comes in handy
so a note you could use both universal
or donut as a as a module system for
your implant so a note on why you might
want to do one or the other
so basically uh donuts you can make run
in a in a
in a process all by themselves uh
universal will try and load a library in
your current process there are a few
situations that will break universal uh
because there are things that don't like
running not on the main thread
for example minicats
starts up some com hosting stuff that
doesn't work right if it's not on the
main thread
so i don't think it's ever going to work
right in universal
which means uh but it works fine through
donut as we'll see um and uh there's
also a go scheduler bug that's linked
and um so you can
often run into problems if you try and
load two go runtimes in the same thread
so if you're loading uh another go
program with universal
you might be better off with donut
instead just to avoid although it is
possible um
it is easier to avoid having two
run times in one uh process
um
and uh so you can just use donut instead
of universal in that situation there's
another payload creation framework
called scarecrow which is very popular
and definitely worth checking out it
does some kind of funny stuff
it signs its loader using limelighter as
we mentioned before even if you don't
give it a cert it'll just sign it anyway
as a way of reducing edr signal and it's
kind of unique and most badass feature
is that it implements uh it disables the
windows event toolkit which a lot of
edr's uh rely on uh by unhooking itself
uh in memory from edr uh or sorry from
etw
uh which is super cool and worth uh
checking out
and this is open source too so that's
like um
code worth stealing
or just use scarecrow a lot of people do
um so
now
banana phone i almost put in the core
components category uh it is so cool and
so important and so awesome for edr
evasion uh it is an implementation of
hell's gate or direct system calls uh in
go
there's a link to the original paper
here but basically what that means there
are stubs in ntdl uh that uh everything
is in windows is compiled to use that
then in turn calls system calls
but those stubs in ntdl are commonly
hooked or monitored by
edr
and so you can just
parse ntdl because it's already loaded
in your process i guarantee so you can
look at your own process memory look at
ntdll
figure out where those direct system
calls go set up a call frame yourself
and just call them directly and not
bother going through ntdl thus avoiding
hooks that's what hell's gate is so
banana phone is a completely transparent
implementation of hell's gate it's very
easy to port existing go code that uses
syscall to banana phone
because sisto
was kind enough to uh make a version of
the make wind syscall utility that
converts headers
to uh go stubs he made a version of that
called make direct win syscall uh which
converts headers to hell's gated uh go
stubs and it works exactly the same way
as syscall so it's just mad easy to
convert syscall code over highly
recommend doing that it also has a
unique improvement over traditional
hell's gate
found kind of by accident
but there's an auto mode will actually
detect when your in-memory nt dll has
been hooked by edr and automatically
fall back to reloading a fresh copy of
ntl from disk instead of the hooked
version the one on disk will not be
hooked and you can parse the one on disk
to
figure out where the to make the direct
syscalls to and it works just as well
and although this creates theoretically
more signal because loading another copy
of ntdll is sketchy
in practice
this actually works pretty well uh it
works on one of the more popular edr's
uh without triggering anything
so that's kind of neat
there's there's also an implementation
of heaven's gate in go
uh
called go for heaven and this is another
edr of asian technique uh where you call
a 64-bit code from 32-bit code because
nobody is expecting 32-bit code boy
um
and so this is pretty slick
and this also has a really great example
of 32-bit 386 uh go assembly um
in case you need that for some reason
this is one of the few examples uh that
works
all right um so we've gone over a bunch
of ddr uh evasion and nids of asian
tools uh let's go on to post
exploitation uh which is super fun
because it's the loot
so go mimi cats uh basically this
combines go donut and banana phone
uh it downloads mimikatz to memory makes
it into a donut payload injects it into
itself
into its own process that banana phone
system calls and it lets you run
mimikats on systems where you really
shouldn't be able to the whole program
is 150 lines of code this is the best
example of banana phone and go donut um
there's the godo nut bit up top the
banana phone bit down bottom i couldn't
fit 150 lines in a slide but you can
pull it up in a browser i made a quick
demo i cross compiled go mimi cats
to windows amd64 that's all you have to
do to cross compile and go by the way
super easy i copied it to an smb share
with the name gm exe i did not garble it
and i set up a 110 edge uh let it update
defender is enabled i'm running from smv
and uh
i got the little like uh
proof strings up
and then i just run it and bam baby cats
runs nothing flags
and i can interact with it which is just
crazy so that's current maybe cats
current 110 edge
um you will get caught by behavioral
stuff once you start doing stuff in mimi
cats so you will have to do some other
trickery to avoid the behavioral
detections
there's another utility worth checking
out from virus
uh called msflib which uh makes your
implants work with metasploit it has all
of the like metasploit url generation
magic
it also uses panaphone it also has code
to run a payload in the current process
or inject a payload into a remote
process very cool very worth checking
out
writing a windows service and go can be
a little bit of a pain in the ass
there's an example link there
but
captain space hook has made the
taskmaster utility that a lot of people
use to interact with the windows task
scheduler as a method of persistence
to avoid having to create a windows
service you can just schedule a task to
run your thing periodically definitely
check that out
gscript is a whole other talk there was
a defcon 26 talk on it
it uses an embedded javascript
interpreter to make a scripting language
for droppers there's like a thousand
sample g-scripts in oz uh g-script repo
that do things like disable a v
edr firewalls you can make registry
changes you can set up persistence you
can do all kinds of things
so definitely check out g-script it's a
completely
other you know hour-long talk
another tool from sisto uh for dit
dumping this is another thing that
impact does uh but impacted in python is
very slow it takes hours to dump a dit
uh cstos tool can do it in minutes um
definitely check that out uh if you want
to dump hashes from a dit
and the old lasagna tool that steals uh
browser passwords mail passwords all
kinds of passwords it's been parted to
go uh go lasagna however it does require
sigo which means you need to set up an
external c compiler however the only
reason it needs sego is because of a
dependency on sql lite because the
browser password databases are sql lite
databases but there is now a pure go
implementation of sql lite
which i've linked
so someone someday will
modify go lasagna to no longer require
sigo and that would be lovely thank you
there's a few other post exploitation
tools you should check out including
pseudofisher which is hilarious
from audible blink
that actually is an ask pass replacement
that will log the pseudo password so
that's just like a
a funny thing to do and also our clone
is just a utility to uh loot things from
cloud storage
um so those may come in handy and then
we have a couple of complete c2
frameworks entirely implemented in go
the heavy hitter in the space is sliver
which is an open source alternative to
cobalt strike it's coming along it's
under active development
it's designed to be used used by a team
so the the c2 uh is multi-user
multi-operator which is pretty awesome
it has a huge list of features it has an
implant build and obfuscate framework um
there's so much in there i don't have
time to go into definitely check out the
wiki on their github for instructions on
how to set it up and check out the dev
branches because they have a lot of
really cool stuff uh cooking um
and peer pressure them into doing their
own defcon talk at some point
uh another c2 framework uh definitely
worth mentioning is merlin
uh the only downside of merlin is that a
single opera single operator but it has
some unique features that are not really
in anything else it supports a ton of
injection methods but the one that that
sticks out is it has an implementation
in go of q user apc
um
definitely worth checking that out uh it
also has integration with donut and
another common loader which is srdi
and it does support many c2 protocols
also like slipper uh but it has quick
support uh which is pretty cool
uh so that's my time uh thank you very
much um
as a reminder i do host a podcast called
hack the planet and uh there are a few
uh interviews we've done on hack the
planet relevant to this talk we have an
interview with josh pitts which is
phenomenal the the author of ebola and
uh the original backdoor factory uh and
we have another episode entirely on
golang malware featuring sisto and
captain space hook the authors of some
of the utilities i mentioned earlier
so thank you very much
by defcon 29
and
i hope i gave you uh some ideas uh
for
writing going malware or even you know
improving detections or reversing for
golden miller